We begin at Troy, besieged by King Agamemnon and his Greek army.
The stubborn king offends Achilles, the Greeks' best warrior,....
...by claiming his spoil of war, the maiden Briseis.
Achilles leaves the battlefield, honor affronted,...
...so Achilles' mother, Thetis, asks Zeus...
...to let the Trojans have the upper hand...
...to show the Greeks they need her son.
For now, there's a truce, although Paris, a lover not a warrior,...
...is almost killed in a duel with Helen's husband.
Heading into battle, Trojan champion Hector...
...says an emotional goodbye to his wife and child.
The fighting resumes, spurred on by the gods,...
...and the Trojans are winning.
Achilles still refuses to fight,...
...but the Greeks know their foes fear him.
So his best friend Patroclus tries to fool the Trojans...
...by wearing Achilles' armor...
...and is killed in battle  by Hector.
Enraged, Achilles vows revenge.
Wearing armor, newly fashioned by Hephaestus the blacksmith god,...
...he re-enters the battle and slays Hector.